شهد مركز المؤتمرات
شيكاغو ماكور ماك فليس حدثا فارقا على مدى
يومين انه يتعلق ب اول سياره مطبوعه
بتقنيه فريدي او التقنيه ثلاثيه الابعاد
اسم السياره استراتي وهي كلمه ايطاليه
تعني الطبقات وتم تجربتها لاول مره هنا
ويقول جيد جيد من لو كان متواجد ان هذه
السياره مصنعها من اقل من خمس نقطه وشركه
هي جزء من الفريق الذي اشرف على العمليات
الهندسيه لتصنيع سياره كامله بالياف
الكربون البلاستيكيه وطباعتها باستخدام
طابعه فريدي كبيره اعدتها شركه سينسيناتي
انكوربوريتد في ما كورمك ليس طبقه فوق
طبقه ويقول جاي ان بعض هذه السيارات
سيتضمن محركات الاحتراق الداخلي تعمل
بالديزل والبترا ومنها ما سيعمل بمحركات
كهربائيه
مثل هذه وفي اول مره تخضع فيها للتجربه
بلغت السياره سرعه 4 اميال في الساعه
ويقول رجل ان تكلفه السياره تتراوح من
الثمانيه عشر الفا الى ثلاثين الف دولار
كما انه يمكن التغيير العديد من قطعها عند
الضروره بالاضافه الى اعاده استخدام بعض
القطع من دون الحاجه الى ميكانيكيه او الى
نقلها الى ورشه اصلاحات